bienvenido de nuevo voy a hacer un par
de problemas más de razones de cambio
pues el primero que hicimos fue más
complicado de lo que hubiera querido no
tanto por la parte de cálculo sino por
la geometría del problema
digamos que tiramos una roca en un lago
esto genera una onda que se expande de
hecho genera varias ondas pero nos
enfocaremos en una sola de ellas
esta onda entonces se expande digamos
que aquí es el punto donde cayó la
piedra
y esta sería la forma que genera la onda
es una circunferencia que bueno no es
exactamente un círculo pero se parece
entonces digamos que la distancia desde
donde la roca cayó al lago hasta dónde
va la onda se llama r&r no es por rocas
sino eres por radio la distancia de
donde se encuentra la onda con respecto
al centro es esta r supongamos que la
onda se está moviendo dos metros por
segundo es decir la razón a la que
cambia esa distancia con respecto al
tiempo es dos metros por segundo de eren
de t es igual a dos metros por segundo y
lo que queremos saber es qué tan rápido
está cambiando el área el área de esta
región la que está incluida dentro de la
onda que tan ratio está cambiando esa
área con respecto al tiempo de jaén dt
cuando
cuando digamos la onda se encuentra a 3
metros es decir la distancia de la onda
al centro es r igual a 3 metros
ahora bien conocemos alguna relación
entre el área generada por la onda y el
radio de esta onda
si la conocemos y ésta es
área
es igual a pi por radio al cuadrado el
área de una circunferencia cuando
conozco su radio queremos saber la razón
de cambio del área con respecto al
tiempo que nos dice la regla de la
cadena la regla de la cadena nos dice
que la razón de cambio de a con respecto
a t es igual a la razón de cambio de a
con respecto a r por la razón de cambio
de r con respecto a t pero que sabemos
esto de aquí ya lo conocemos la tasa a
la que cambia el radio con respecto al
tiempo y hacemos que es igual a 2
y queremos averiguar la tasa a la que
cambia el área con respecto al tiempo es
lo que queremos encontrar y tenemos que
calcular entonces la tasa de cambio de a
con respecto a r pero esa es la derivada
de esta expresión vamos a calcular la le
diremos a ambos lados la derivada con
respecto a r de a
esto es igual a la diva con respecto a r
d
i
por el cuadrado así que tenemos del lado
izquierdo de a de r
y del lado derecho cual la derivada de
esto con respecto a r esto es fácil y es
re cuadrada sería 2
por r a la 12 pies y esto es interesante
en sí veamos qué es lo que nos está
diciendo nos dice que la derivada del
área con respecto al radio
es 2 pierre en la cual la fórmula del
perímetro del círculo la longitud de la
circunferencia entonces la derivada del
área con respecto al radio es la
circunferencia eso es realmente
fascinante algo que puede ser más
fascinante aún y lo puede checar en
wikipedia o en algún otro medio es qué
pasa cuando tú derivas el volumen de una
esfera con respecto al radio cuando tu
derivas el volumen de una esfera con
respecto al radio lo que obtienes es la
fórmula del área de se espera la fórmula
del área superficial desespera en base
al radio y así tomar derivadas sucesivas
y ver qué sucede pero bueno ya estamos
divagando mucho y nos estamos alejando
del problema regresemos entonces a
nuestro problema original tenemos que la
tasa de cambio de a con respecto a r es
igual a dos pies y queremos calcular la
tasa de cambio de a con respecto a t
entonces de allende t es igual la tasa
de cambio de a con respecto a r que aquí
la tenemos la tasa de cambio de a con
respecto a él que es 2 pierde 2 pierde
la tasa de cambio de recorre especto ate
aquí la tenemos de eren de té y de red
de té es el valor inicial de 22 metros
por segundo entonces sería dos pies por
dos no le ponemos unidades para no hacer
más complicada la expresión entonces la
tasa a la que a cambia con respecto al
tiempo es dos pies por dos ya hemos
acabado no tenemos que sustituir el
valor de r y cuál es ese valor de r aquí
lo tenemos eres igual a 3 entonces la
tasa a la que a cambiar con respecto a t
es igual a 2 por 3 por 2 2 por 3 6 por 2
12 12 pi y esto está en metros cuadrados
por segundo pues es la razón a la que el
área metros cuadrados varía con respecto
al tiempo y subieron multiplicado las
unidades obtendríamos lo mismo aquí en
el siguiente vídeo haré un problema un
poquito más complicado de razones de
cambio para que veas que aplica no tan
sólo a problemas geométricos sino a
problemas en que hay varias
relacionada entre dos cantidades nos
vemos en el siguiente módulo